shane in your new book what you don't
learn in film school was there a chapter
or
section that sparked controversy oh
absolutely
um i think the most controversial
chapter in the book is the one that's
the most important and that's to get out
dig ditches get your hands dirty and
make yourself available and whatever it
takes to get
on a set within your morals values and
ethics parameter
to go do it and when i came up
as we talked about how i made phone
calls and hustled to get work and get on
sets i worked for free i brought my own
lunch
i showed up first and left last i was
sweeping floors when it wasn't in my job
description and i have
close friends that our generation grew
up
you know i have a friend whose father
won two oscars and his mother has nine
emmys
you want to talk about nepotism and when
he got his act together like i did he
said hey you know yeah i want to work in
this business i want to be an editor
mom picked up the phone made a phone
call okay he'll be there tomorrow
two o'clock perfect thank you click
you got a job you're sweeping floors it
color deluxe
you're getting paid nothing pack a
launch deer and he swept floors
deluxe for two years i think it was
deluxe and
he didn't have a problem with that he
thought that's normal
um i had won emmys at a young age and
started over and we talked about not
being able to make rent well there was
something called crew call back when i
was coming up
and you would literally subscribe for
like 50 a month
you would call an 800 number and you
would say you know press one for camera
press two for sound press free for
you know electric and you would press
these things that you could do
and then you would hear about jobs and
you would write it down and it would
give you a fax number and you would fax
your resume you would spend a day a week
doing that
and pray your phone rang and sometimes
it wouldn't
so a friend would call and say hey i
need a i need a swing
in the camera department tomorrow i pay
lunch you enter out and i was like yeah
i'm there
the biggest problem i have today is when
i talk to film schools or when people
read that chapter
about having to invest in yourself and
build your resume you know so many
people are in my opinion in film school
are sold on hopes and dreams
and um being the next tarantino or
damian chazelle
and my advice is well if that doesn't
happen what's the game plan
so get out and learn camera learn sound
learn editing
learn grit learn gaff learn ac whatever
you can
and if somebody can't pay you to do
something and you have an opportunity to
make new contacts
learn and be on a set something good
will come from that
do you would you rather sit home and
play on your phone or play xbox or watch
repeated
streaming shows that you've seen six
times you want to get out and make new
contacts
and i find a lot of people uh think
that's not the way to do it and i also
think okay well
over 85 percent of people who spend
money and graduate from film schools
never earn a dime in our industry
and there's a reason for it and that's
because they are uneducated on how to
make their lives work and how to build
a career base and contacts and become
steady earners in our business and the
way i did it the way i know a lot of
people who did it
was they got out there and proved their
worth by
hustling and some of the best workers
like we just finished a film called
break even that comes out
some of the best workers on that film
were the interns from lake pierce
college
there's a kid that stands out
he worked so hard every day
never said a word head down he
anticipated everybody's needs he was the
guy that was cleaning up everybody's
trash at the end of the night
showed up on days he wasn't supposed to
be there just because he wanted to check
in
say i'm coming in tomorrow does anybody
need anything you know
what i always tell people is when you
make a movie and you're trying to carve
your way
make it so the decision makers don't
want to make a movie without you
and every time you do a film you sure
meet a lot of people you never want to
make another movie with
but it's nice when you see those one or
two diamonds in a rough that you say god
i
i want to bring them back and they were
they were somebody who was a pa they
were
an assistant they were a runner and i
think if people take that approach as
as i say in the book whenever you offer
somebody a job it's
what's my credit what's my pay it's
always the first question
what's my credit what's my pay and i
think it needs to
be okay you know take a breath
and think about what the experience can
do for you i mean i talked in the same
chapter i talk about the the best thing
i ever did for my career was say yes to
something i knew nothing about
i did it for free and it took up a month
and a half of my life
and that was going to valley indonesia
with zalman king when he directed in
god's hands
solomon had seen my work ethic around a
sound stage he owned in canoga park
i was sweeping floors he was like he
walked in and he goes i thought you were
producing or
doing something more important i said
yeah everybody left i wanted to leave
your studio the way we found it and he
says what's your name and he came over
and he talked to me and
we befriended each other and he came and
visited the next day on set and
next thing you know he called me up and
he said hey what are you doing in
november or december
and i said i don't know what do you got
and he said well i'm doing a film in
bally i think i think you should come
i said do what he said shadow me learn
he goes i'll offer you free education
working with me and
and we'll feed you and travel you and
you figure out the rest you didn't pay
me a dime
and it was it was like talk about film
school you're sitting next to zalman
fricking king as he's directing a movie
for a major studio
and i was on his hip for a month and a
half doing that and i learned more
by just saying yes and it asks would i
get a credit and what i get paid
you know and they limited me to the
airport and first class me round trip
gave me my own bungalow and in a
five-story resort i didn't ask for any
of that i didn't i probably know i'd be
sleeping in a tube tent on the side of a
mountain
you know but they took care of me and uh
i think
that's the attitude obviously you don't
want to be taken advantage of you don't
want to get into a situation that's not
healthy but
there seems to be such resistance in
getting out and
experiencing work without worrying about
pay there's too many people that'll do
it
do you think that's because for you know
our generation gen x
that there wasn't the term intern you
know and some of
let's play the devil's advocate yes
interns can be taken advantage of in
terms of
absolutely people using free labor and
and not stringing them along and not
giving them a job
is that what they're afraid of i don't
know i think honestly
i think as a society we have become
pretty tender i think we become very
sensitive and i think people are afraid
of exploitation which i think
is something we all need to consider but
you know
i i know i've got a nephew who worked as
his you know what off working for a
financial institution in arizona
and scottsdale working 18 hours a day
getting their lunch
cleaning up their mess getting them
coffee you didn't get paid much at all
but now he's
an actual worker in that industry and he
used that
after colleges wasn't for college
credits he graduated college
his dad made a few phone calls and said
you're going to go sweat you're going to
wear a tie and you're going to go
you're going to go ride their their wave
you're not going to get paid you're
going to learn
it happens in other industries but
it just seems in ours i think it's
because the hours are abused
you know and if in a normal workplace
it's an eight hour work day with an hour
break in film it's 10 to 12 if you're
lucky
and i think people are afraid they're
going to be working 16 18 hours a day is
free labor
so it's hard to say why but i never
questioned that i
maybe maybe it was just the fact that i
could be on a set and make connections
and learn and i always figured well
i could sit at home and wait for the
phone to ring or i could be on a set and
meet a director or a producer who may
find my my job skills
necessary to bring me to the next
journey and then make a great connection
and say by the way i have a script
by the way you know i also do camera can
i get an opportunity
and it doesn't happen by sitting at home
just doesn't
great okay excellent at least i don't
think it does i mean you can upload
youtube and vimeo until you're blue in
the face
yeah but working with you know being
around people is a different experience
absolutely
there's good and bad best gigs and best
opportunities i ever had in my life were
showing up and working hard
improving myself as a worker who was
competent
and the people in the decision-making
capacities going out of their way to say
hey you know appreciate your work today
thank you and then
you know we've got something coming up
next week i want to get you on that
and then they start to appreciate you
and you work these gigs and
next thing you know you have an audience
you have an ear with the decision makers
and when you want to move up in the
world or they know people that will
benefit by knowing you
that's all it is in this business
you